a very good evening and sorry for the
delay thank you from the European
Council to all journalists following us
for this press conference following the
videoconference these are extraordinary
circumstances and we understand that
these circumstances are also very
challenging for all media following us
we've taken all precautions to ensure
everyone stays safe and that's why this
press conference is completely virtual
the president of the European Council is
joined by the president of the
Commission in the press room of the
Commission following the statements by
the two presidents we'll take questions
that were massively forwarded to the
council press service but first I give
the floor to the president of the
European Council well good evening
first of all I would like to thank you
for your presence for this video
conference
we had the occasion for the first time
in three weeks to have European councils
meeting with a video conference it was
important to monitor the situation in
order to be certain that we are able to
do the follow-up of what we have taken
as political orientations the last weeks
and you know that we have decided to
work on five concrete priorities first
we continue to take measures and to
coordinate with the Member States in
order to limit and to reduce the spread
of the virus is essential because it's
important to try to strengthen our
health care system and to reduce and to
limit the spread of the virus we have
also taken important decisions regarding
the border the internal borders and the
external borders and we have observed
that we have made a lot of progress and
you know that our priority is to reduce
the not essential
the travels of people but at the same
time to maintain and even to guarantee
the flow of routes which is very
important in order to avoid the
shortages and to protect as much as
possible the senior market the certain
important point is the medical equipment
how is it possible to provide more
medical equipment to assist the Member
States and we had the occasion to be
informed about the progress we made in
the different procedures which I've
started on this topic is of course very
important to continue all the efforts at
the national level at the open level in
order in order to provide the equipment
for the health workers especially third
point is the research and will continue
also at the international level we had a
video conference today with the g20 to
be part of a common strong commitment in
order to develop and to produce the
vaccines we need as soon as possible and
the therapies we need as soon as
possible
the Catalan poor population economic
measure home like a pro hockey
fatblueman
often the consequence economic adonde
transition social internal trade
important leader Nehru the real rapido
littleman would impact young mobile is
the malapa veneer on sutiya the sector
kiss on determine to see polymerase
treaties the international economic
impact on you see the suit on you solve
this issue here please la comisión a
palace to the finals only avid packed
the transponder stability
don't tell you tell lie close response
you IT activist on the maximum nerve
exceptional was it immoral to new the
second source exceptional you see the
very day the Pope was notified polyp
with the flexibility don't charge regime
desi the data infer loss on TM poor poor
artist whom you habit
no the Citroen ax haparanda PTA for
Kayla you see when you open a vegetable
position in the computed repo on
television Hypatia literally opened
apparently over log P revolution the
nation's political extreme mo dos Santos
de Rojo support a doll portion seminal
report on mo Angelo Dundee the poor
children have a Absalom Oh Antone's
show deplore the opposition supported
off a pony at renewal services
ESS apart economic ESS on patrol applaud
a stability no pain relief on OCD do
darken fear Allah for avato servitor
mercy al upon a commission or open seek
a vegan capacity consultation trans
institutions special mo lab on propane
Avenue trolley
Sharon plon Holland's SEO strategy digit
Paparelli coordination disorganization
Colosimo sot roger twiston d'oeuvre busy
to Le Maire perceive a found approve our
guarantee Ikuo MOA um capacity
DNA the prosperity poor vulnerable
Palestrina purple if a me upon ensemble
des entreprises special manipulated a -
on purpose on amo la derecha
some a service permanence a necessity a
total mama will defer defer Dakin video
ends even FEA demostración
no capacity por si also important
illusionist
bataki to invert a remand sec porque el
amor de confrontational or Pareto front
an-72 Zito's ryokan pencil napoo imposes
advisor on travelin arsenic operational
reality Doheny to canoe Peru guarantee
her 200 us your preneur mal
now we go to the president of the
European Commission
yes sir thank you and good evening from
my part we are now several weeks into
the crisis and this is why it is
important to ensure that we coordinate
and align as much as possible our
actions both between member states and
between the EU institutions and national
governments and that is why today's
video conference and the European
Council was so important we discussed
with the Member States that we need an
intelligent strategy that at the same
time protects the health of our citizens
and keeps our economy afloat and our
Goods and cross-border workers moving
and it is only this way that we can
provide health services with a medical
gear and equipment they need the
factories with components to build
ventilators for example and our
supermarkets with the goods to fill
their shelves the issue of medical
equipment is both crucial and urgent and
as you know the Commission is active on
many fronts it is organizing joint
procurement with Member States the first
results we had this week are promising
it is adopting new EU standards that
means harmonizing between o27 making
relevant ones free of charge and
simplifying procedure we want to ensure
that equipment can be produced more
easily quickly and cheaply it is also
taking a talking to industry as I did
yesterday with the producer for
ventilators to understand how to help
them quickly increase and step up the
production and of course our discussions
also focused on the economic response to
the crisis the Commission is supporting
Member States efforts with all the tools
at its disposal where for example
activated the general escape clause and
this stability and growth pact we have
adopted a temporary state aid framework
that is as flexible as never before
together with these decision give the
Member States
the room of manoeuvre they need at that
moment they need the room to maneuver to
provide businesses for example and
workers with financial support and we
are mobilizing the EU budget to channel
investment to the most urgent needs
notably thanks to the coronavirus
response investment initiative it is
possible now to invest in the labour
market in the healthcare sector or for
example in other businesses that needs
support this Korona a virus response
investment initiative has been adopted
today in the European Parliament a
flexible use of the budget can help us
respond to many challenges in different
sectors like the agriculture or
fisheries so we also look into that but
we must be very clear we are in the
final year of a 7 year budget this
crisis shows how important indeed
crucial it is to have a budget that can
deal with complex crises such as this
ones this calls for an ambitious new
European budget that will support the EU
economy to recover on one hand and
hopefully make it possible for the
economy to rebound as soon as conditions
allow it such a rebound requires first a
well thought through
exit strategy we all have measures in
place these containment measures social
discontent Singh to contain the spread
of the virus and to slow down the spread
of the virus now we need to coordinate
our decisions when at a certain time we
want to go back to normal because
otherwise we will undermine the
effectiveness of the tough measures we
took we discussed this today we will
develop such an exit strategy for our
European Union this should be based on a
science-based approach a science-based
protocol proposing when and how to move
away from for example the
or distancing measures we will be
working on this protocols with
scientists and experts and we will work
together as Sean Michel just explained
on a recovery strategy this should allow
our economy to kind of kickstart again
when the right moment has come because
we should not forget we have healthy
companies and those have to bridge the
gap to the time when the economy is
picking up again the orders come in
again they have to hibernate till them
last but not least as Jean Michel just
said today we took part in the video
conference of g20 leaders we are in a
global crisis that requires a global
response and I therefore offered that
the European Commission hosts an online
pledging event an online pledging event
to fund the development of a vaccine
against kovat 19 this based on the
initiative the global initiatives we
know very well for example sepi or the
global preparedness monitoring board we
need solidarity among EU Member States
but we also need solidarity across the
globe thank you thank you to the
president of the Commission we have
received many questions of course on the
socio-economic response to the kovat 19
crisis and I'm going to start with a
question from Reuters eunsuk jeff key
the first question to both presidents is
have you discussed the letter of 9 EU
leaders calling for a common debt
instruments in response to the epidemic
and what were the conclusions will there
be joint debt issuance in the eurozone
we have indeed discussed all the
different possibilities in order to be
able to face this challenge that the
economic 11 and we took the decision to
continue all our efforts based
on a very stern commitment we are ready
to do everything it takes in order to do
to find the right solution but indeed we
need to continue our efforts which the
yoga group and the your group will give
within two weeks
a new report with proposals we had
tonight a very strong political debate
it was a useful debate it was a
necessary debate because we will show
that on many topics we are on the same
page and on different topic we need to
continue the Patel Dayal dialogue
between us in order to to be united
thank you there's little to add indeed
over the past weeks we all have been
very working very hard to put in place
measures to help the economy to
hibernate and to fight the crisis
coronavirus crisis in the health sector
and all institutions have contributed to
that so the member states heavily by
investing in their economies but also
the European Central Bank the EIB and
the Commission's for example with the
general escape clause or the state aid
and the corona response investment
initiative and these all these measures
have been put forward now I think they
have to sink in now but indeed the room
is open for discussing all other
possibilities that might be on the table
and therefore the tasking was very
precise today from the council towards
the European towards the Euro group
thank you I have another question by
Jack Barak from euronews if or when the
corona bonds are blocked
are you already discussing and
suggesting some other ways of proving to
European citizens that the EU can work
together on this
to the President of the European Council
and then to the President of the
European Commission but I think it's
very important to explain what we have
done to date together with the members
say together with institutions the the
last days in order to make more progress
in Zurich on Crete the Fed that we took
this decision regarding the gross party
gives more possibility for the member
states to take very strong international
decisions the Fed the Dupin central bank
last week has announced a very strong
decision it has already operative effect
and the fact that which the ministers of
finance we are discussing in order to
see what are the possible tools we can
use in case of necessity in the next
weeks in the next month and the question
is also of course to be to be ready to
have the tools and to choose the right
moment when we think is useful to use
the tools we have also a determinate
level yes to add to that
indeed the measures that have been put
out allow member states right now to put
a lot of liquidity into the economy in
the Member States we also for example
look into all the structural funds and
other funds like in agricultural and
fisheries where we can mobilize more and
give more flexibility to the member
states to use that money that is there
already and to put it into different
sectors with a lot of flexibility and
with that I think it is important to
keep in mind that looking forward the
strongest sign for European solidarity
is a strong European budget this will
have to be discussed over the next weeks
we will have to come to a solution but
this is a strong sign that is backing
the European economy and that is showing
that a strong solidarity between the
European member states and support for
the European Union
thank you very much we received a number
of questions on nff notably on
the European budget I will take a
question in French by a John Hope
Matthew byung-ho please don't leak on
say European and I curse of like a
fiance bling annual if you don't go off
visage habla I've known immigrants
darker blue busy hotel is a stream on
approval disposal poor active in
strategy the kotoha Osetra knows her
pain tapas of the other said twist
Circle C power democracy interior
sanitary poderosas Remo from the
bottom-up analysis more into to know the
next main accompany you receive a
console table attend no leads it a more
like a strong visual hopper I found
approval up Casey I tell mama or Papa
annual engage in this recent use of
Sevilla is a part are Lupino its prima
donna crimson European elite important
baccarat see pastor dispositive
vigilante renewal said well disposed
Amalia this one assessor approval after
contest Nova drawn affronti not
emotionally no see shall applaud the the
DC you can do some confront a little
more comedic legend the digital no power
dissipation past yes please governor
leaves open travelpod member gsella
molester une des le monstre cure
police'll probably more with the most
tricky or the particle of what we see in
strategy European the hollows is what
involuntary [ __ ] on business of the
city I have a question for both
presidents from Louis with Danish
business daily Boston from the
conclusions I understand that the
Commission and the council will be a
will be asked to work on an exit
strategy or a recovery plan a roadmap
what is the timeframe and deadlines for
these plans to be presented we have
indeed stone men did they put on the
Commission and myself in order to to
propose a roadmap to propose a strategy
because we understand it is very
important to be to be ready and to
prepare the possibility to ever to have
a strong coordination in this exists why
in order to be able to come back to a
more normal situation and to take
coordinate coordinated decisions with
this perspective but another important
signal is the fact that we need a week
of which strategy and we need to use all
the possible tools and me it means that
the open budget is one of the possible
tools but I think that the single market
and the improvement of the single market
is also one of the possible tools we can
use in order to strengthen our
capacities in the short term in the mid
term and in the long term I think indeed
the exit strategy is more focused on the
question well we more or less all Member
States had to slow down public life this
slowed down the economy drastically and
in some Member States there was a
complete or is a complete lockdown and
we have now to look with our scientists
the epidemiologist and the biologist
first of all what they recommend as time
frame and as factors that you have to
take into account when to lift the one
or the other measure and in word regions
this is important and we are modernizing
on that different scenarios this is the
scientific approach what the virus is
concerned but indeed this is accompanied
with the question well this is the the
rekindling of the economy and then they
have to be in place two things indeed
very crucial is a strong European budget
but very crucial is also to have our
single market going again and to make
sure that the supply chains function
that the supply chains worldwide
function again therefore it is a double
approach to just get the mechanics back
going that we're in place but have been
interrupted by all the measures taken to
fight the virus and on top back the
European economy by a strong European
budget
we have received a number of questions
on the European the European Bank for
investments in French as well
dilash Jones depress Italian is soul
event de cuatro Antonio polio Saleem
been another over yes it's question
every discrete a do whole the lab baby
poor the play of the home for sale a
system the protection controller fromage
is he in oak Montes on the capital
settle necessarily duty zero never said
Victor dollar media books on the area
visions of a propos de Leon parallel in
this video hope era when they so dude
Montero capital about openness is no is
restr converted to tota on the Ralph
Aaron soccer LaVon troponin C small D
supposed ammonia additional Pavel V to
the DC volcanoes and confront a report
on effect Colonel aboard openness is no
eternal partner profit strategies the
whole knows economic
even necessarily twist it apart on
elusive lead led earlier with no vision
digital normally see on porous or no
climatic in Cameroon on it what to
presume avid Direction about European
service module do the Parliament repair
a daughter voltage on the home foxy
senior elite about raha Pandavas is more
I founded plane more mobile disease will
applaud the lamp will soon democratic
hipoteca Dhoni
Madam President what everything has been
said so this was exactly the point that
has been said by Jean Michel I do not
have to add anything on that I have a
couple of more questions with regards to
the disinformation in French and in
English our first start with a question
by Athanasius from Cyprus on this
information for both presidents what
measures are you going to take against
the disinformation campaign launched
currently against the EU to exploit the
kovat 19 crisis since thousands of
trolls operate daily downplaying the EU
response to be transparent and to be
honest and to explain what's the reality
but indeed we have observed that the
last days the last week we face again
fate news fake rumors and it's important
to me the clarity and we count also on
the responsibility of the press because
we return Z that in the more in a
democracy it's essential that the press
place fully each fall we count on on you
but it's not enough we consider also at
the international level at the
geopolitical level that it's important
to to implement a strategy in order to
fight against these fake news operations
and that's why we have asked especially
to the high repetitive borehole to work
with us to work with the Member States
with the Commission in order to to have
a more current and stronger approach
against the Fate news in general and
especially in those current
circumstances well concerning fake news
there are different types that have to
be fought first of all a counterfeit and
fraud is a typical thing that is
connected to coverage 19 so listening to
Europe all shows that they
very active on fighting these
counterfeit and fraud websites that are
producing malware and that are producing
or offering products that are certainly
not fit for purpose and there the
numbers are impressive if you look on
the Europol wet website what is being
offered internet-based and how they are
able to fight it and there's a second
topic indeed this is the pure topic of
fake news here I think the European
Union over time will have to step up to
systematically look at what's out there
and systematically dismantle these fake
news there are there is quite a lot of
experience by now out there how you can
on a systematic way
look at these fake news and show that
and why they are fake news so put the
evidence behind as beside that so to
prove that these are fake news and this
is a topic I think this will be
accompanying us forever it will not go
away and therefore I think we have to
step up here and I think within the
commission structures in the cyber
security field this focus on fighting
the subject of fake new has to be
reinforced I have a question in French
jean cusamano ladies I promise you no
please don't do you can say concrete no
convolve with a country like this I
promise you the transponder
Annette is reported on diversity mo Eau
de Paula pain at Grenoble is a poor
demolish a quarter in the first
informatio a community in una musica
biack yeah dolma satin envelope Morgana
speedo paper foie de Sol mobile is a
diffuser party pad more me person or via
levitus issue the forces informational
supply above the
you said he knew about it on television
we travel on T the movie the devil turn
to play Xhosa European I found a
favorite release
- posture said to Popeye - wonderful
news a to inform Dominus if we if
they're more developed so trial for
European Liberty depressed
responsibility depressed in majority
yella Lucia Holt has a portfolio
provided askew me I have one last
question before we end this press
conference by Politico for both the
president's did the leaders discuss any
possibility of further coordinating the
social distancing measures and lockdown
provisions with an eye toward lifting
them in a coordinated fashion and was
there any discussion of extending the
external essential traveler restrictions
the president's we discussed indeed the
important tool to reduce the spread of
the virus it means that the member
states have taken the national level
very strong measures that we often
confinement measures and we see more and
more the same approach at the national
level between the member states and it's
very essential it was no flavonol an
asset that we organized a common exit
strategy when we will consider based on
science that it is possible to come back
to a more normal life the fact that we
are able to cooperate with more harmonic
approach will be very important and we
took the decision today toward together
the Commission the open council in order
to make some concrete proposals in the
next weeks the spread of the virus
determines the pace at which we are
progressing and indeed for that we need
models for different scenarios the
health advisory panel that we have
created on the Commission's level
consisting of
reknowned experts from different member
states
right now working on these models
together with ac/dc
and will put forward recommendations so
that we can see at the stage where the
spread of the virus is or the numbers of
infected of cases of disease are and
then decide related to their
recommendation where and when slowly but
surely these measures can be lifted and
you know we're in this constant dilemma
because of the virus we have to slow
down public life we have to lock down
partly in order not to over stretch the
healthcare system but on the other side
every single day costs a lot of economic
power and therefore it's a permanent
trade of not to lift too early
concerning the virus and the rebounds
potentially of the virus and not to lift
too late concerning the economy which is
really having a hard time with these
confinement measures and therefore the
scientific based approach I think is
very good for the European Union then we
have a measure and we have clear
criterias with those we can work in the
different member states if you allow me
one last questions especially from
Italian news agencies on ESM can we have
an answer on the European Stability
Mechanism for both presidents you know
that the new group I started to discuss
different proposals the ESM included and
we have asked your group to continue and
to made some proposals within two weeks
and it will give us the possibility at
the level of the open council to discuss
the different possible measures and the
important signal is based on the fact
that each member state we recognize that
this crisis is exceptional is unique and
it requires a very strong answer exactly
there has been the tasking of the
Eurogroup and in within the conclusion
is very clear how the task has been
designed and I think it was a timeframe
of two weeks in which that the Eurogroup
has to come back then with proposals
thank you for both presidents and thank
you to the press for following us during
this press conference we're looking
forward to seeing you in real life again
and in the meantime stay safe
[Music]
you